hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's arrow flash Q&A just like
normal I'm going to start with flash
stuff and then I'll get into arrow
questions and another bunch of big
questions about time travel what's going
on with the groundhogs day situation
what's up with like the two really big
WTF reveals on arrow so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the
episodes yet I'll start with the easy
stuff on the flash the easy time travel
explainers so yes episode 16 is going to
be buried reliving most of the events
from episode 15 that includes the
conclusion of awkward date remember
because he bailed in the date like early
on finding weather wizard faster and as
a result of those things he'll probably
bump into cisco earlier in cause cisco
to do something differently which will
result in Harrison wells not going back
and killing him Cisco's alive and a lot
of the future trailer footage so clearly
something changes to save his life
remember the only people that found out
about Harrison wells in the original
timeline where Caitlin and Cisco and
Cisco is really the only one that
completely figured it out Kaitlyn just
knows something's weird that means it's
going to be that much longer before
people figure out who Harrison wells
really is that he's a labar Thawne
that's why you see the trailer footage
with him talking to Gideon going show me
the future or the footage of him from
episode 18 which is way down the line
the atom crossover with him sitting in
front of Ray Palmer suit and there's
been the recent pictures that Rick cos
net has taken with Tom Cavanagh I'm
really interested to see if a labar
Thawne tries to steer Eddie Thawne in a
certain direction to ensure his lineage
for the most part they are sticking with
comic book continuity so iris probably
gets married to bury like she does in
the comics Eddie Thawne goes on to hate
Barry for some reason and many many
years down the road a Bart donned is
born becomes the reverse-flash and
starts the war against Barry Allen
that's where it gets really timey wimey
because it's like you know it's a war in
the future that spills into the past
that feeds the future even more it's
like this giant feedback loop of time
travel think back to arrow season 2 by
the time we got to the last couple
episodes Slade had already taken over
the city and it was all about team arrow
taking him down I think that means the
Barry's gonna learn who Harrison wells
is before episode 21 at least episode 22
at the latest so on to questions all
kinds of time-travel stuff persian
monkey studios asks how did harrison
wells get bloody when he was getting
punched by a recording well so
technically it was like him
punching himself and what they were
watching was a speed Mirage like is he
called it so he really was punching
himself it wasn't like a physical
hologram punching him they're a little
fuzzy on exactly how fast he's moving I
think they'll start to quantify that as
Harrison wells starts to explain time
travel to bury in a deeper way next
question Ryan asks do you think that in
a future season like season four or five
Barry will die and then Wally will take
over to the flash and then bart allen
will be kid flash and arsenal get clone
so so you're thinking you know like
stuff that they've done from the comics
and the cartoons before no I think the
Grant Gustin will always be the main
flash like they'll have other flashes
come on they'll totally do more of the
flash family even like Jesse quick
that'd be cool too I think what'll
happen is is they might come on briefly
but the show will always reset by the
finale I think we'll get to black racer
all kinds of crazy stuff Barry Allen
could get trapped in the Speed Force for
a couple episodes at some point but
he'll always come back like they'll do
their version of arrow killing Oliver
Queen he was away for a while he wasn't
in a couple episodes in a big way so I
think they'll do something like that but
Grant Gustin will always be their lead
actor they've kind of done that in the
comics where you've had like multiple
flash family like where you've had Jay
Garrick and Wally West during the Wally
West run so they'll do stuff like that
where you have more than one flash on a
show but Barry Allen will always be the
main flash next question though dynasty
heroes asks so is Eddie Thawne a villain
then well not not quite yet I think he's
getting there i think by the end of the
season that's what the tease is if they
do turn him into a villain if they do go
straight from the comic books and he's
like a hunter zolomon type character
with a thon name you know as part of the
athan lineage then i think that he would
be the big bad in season 2 it's kind of
like arrow going from Season one to
season two season one Malcolm Merlyn
Oliver's biggest villain he's like the
biggest Green Arrow villain in the
comics two are one of the biggest
villains the season two villain Slade
started out as Oliver's friend so just
like that on the flash Eddie Thawne
starts out as berries friend in season
one becomes the villain in season two I
think that's like a logical place to go
but there will be other villains other
really big villains that includes rogues
Justice League villains anybody else
that they feel would be good match for
the other characters in the show beyond
the second reverse flash I think it's a
little too soon to speculate
on big season two villains gorilla grodd
i think is definitely on the list he's
always going to come back he's way too
amazing to ride the bench next question
WWE fan asks will bury ever interact
with his future self and will bury ever
find out Harrison wells is eddie thawne
i assume you met a Barth on second
question I think I already answered yet
he'll totally figure that out you know
before like the last one or two episodes
as for the other question yeah
definitely he will talk to himself in
that clip from the trailer he's punching
himself so at some point he's going to
try and stop himself from doing
something and his other self will say
you buddy I think episode 16 will
explain a lot of that next question
allen law asks the new Suicide Squad
Amanda Waller Deathstroke boomerang
weather wizard and Nyssa that would be
awesome I don't see like Nyssa I feel
like she's going to take Rachel goals
plays like they'll find a way for Oliver
to back out of the deal and Nyssa to
take his place become the air again
really cupid is like the replacement
person in the Suicide Squad I think
depending on fan reaction to the Suicide
Squad episode next week they'll mix and
match characters every time they bring
the Suicide Squad back on the show it
changes just a little bit because they
don't use it that often but I do think
at some point they'll bring Captain
Boomerang back on as a suicide squad
member if not its season 4 than in
season 5 a lot of that depends on the
actors availability next question bar 2
asks i hope they do flashpoint but how
will they put Batman cyborg Aquaman in
the TV show ok so think about it this
way what is flashpoint all it really is
is the reverse-flash trying to turn
Barry Allen into a living paradox you
really don't need any other characters
for that really the reverse flash just
allows Barry Allen to save his mother
and that completely changes the timeline
via butterfly effect the war between
atlantis and the surface world and all
the other stuff that's going on those
are just side effects they're not
necessary the reverse-flash doesn't care
about them he just cares about killing
Barry Allen in the only way he can do
that is by turning him into a living
paradox so when I talk about flashpoint
paradox with reference to the show
that's what I'm talking about just the
reverse flash eliminating Barry Allen
without eliminating himself from the
timeline next question ooh 2k asks so it
looks like you're asking about to Barry
Allen's in the past
maybe merging and becoming one Barry
Allen no because there's two of them
fighting in the trailer there they're
very clearly going to be two of them one
of them will leave and leave the
original one there I know it gets into
multiverse territory don't overthink it
too much before the show explains it but
I think they'll do is Harrison wells
will explain to Barry how he can return
to the original timeline without messing
stuff up because very clearly a bar thon
has a lot of experience in time
traveling and trying to change the past
without completely messing up his own
future next question David asks so as i
was going to know who the flashes or
will she not knows since Barry went back
in time well she'll only know if Barry
repeats all those events in the same way
he could I think what'll happen is is
he'll do something different and she
won't find out Andrew Kreisberg was
pretty upfront with them having fun with
episode 16 and Barry doing things
differently so i think it'll lead to a
different outcome kind of resetting a
lot of the WTF crap stuff Cisco won't
die iris won't find out Barry will
defeat weather wizard and save Joe that
would just allow things to progress
status quo for the next couple of
episodes is things slowly spin out
control more and more next question yao
asks any chance of the TV flash crossing
over with the movie flash that would be
like the smallest of cameos if it
happens and i don't think it's going to
happen ezra miller is playing the movie
version of the flash it sounds like he's
going to be the Barry Allen flash too
and Warner Brothers is going to be like
TVs and in movies completely different
universes deal with it I've heard rumors
that the Batman V Superman trailer has
footage of Ezra Miller in it as Barry
Allen but there's no confirmation on
that I have no idea what the movie
version of the flash is going to look
like I wouldn't worry about it too much
by the time we actually get to that
flash Green Lantern movie there will be
so many seasons of the TV flash that I
think people will identify more with the
Grant Gustin flash then they will with
the ezra miller flash so moving into
general arrow questions Harry asks if
shadows alive why did Oliver let destro
kill his mother kidnap his sister and go
all crazy in the city I think the
simplest answer is is that that was not
shadow that was either a sister or a
clone it would be pretty WTF if it was a
clone and surprise surprise you know why
would she appear in the one place that
Oliver happens to be that's an awful big
coincidence and why hasn't Oliver
mentioned her in the future either
because she died in the past in the
flashbacks like she'll die eventually or
really is a sister in Oliver was trying
to protect her by not telling Slade
about her just to be clear though that
was the exact same actress that played
shadow and seasons one and two next
question though mark asks since magic is
in the arrow verse I hope they get a
Constantine crossover so I picked this
one for very specific reason I've heard
rumors that Constantine has been
canceled which is sad but that does free
up the character and Matt Ryan to cross
over if they'd gotten picked up because
NBC's the different network it would
just made it nearly impossible for him
to cross over but if it's cancelled an
NBC frees up the character then it's a
lot easier to happen because I think
Matt Brian would totally be down to do
stuff like that that also kind of gets
into actor availability to but there's
some issues with rights and different
networks so it's a little more
complicated it's not a simple answer
next question dark vengeance asks
imagine Rach resurrected Sarah I know
it's impossible but that'd be a big WTF
moment for the season finale well it's
not impossible but i think you know
general assumption is is the caity lotz
we be playing a different character on
the spin-off show I don't feel like they
would have introduced the Lazarus Pit if
they weren't going to resurrect somebody
but that doesn't mean that they couldn't
also resurrect multiple people I would
be very very surprised if they made any
official announcements about who caity
lotz is playing before the arrow finale
this year they might even wait till
comic-con to announce it but they'll be
filming the pilot for this spinoff show
soon so they'll have to have some
outdoor scenes so we will get a look if
she's going to be wearing a costume we
will see what it is it's like somebody
will snipe the set so spoilers are not
spoilers people will find out before the
summer I think what everyone's hoping is
is that she'll come back as Sarah like
it'll be Sarah being resurrected but
it'll be some twisted version of her and
that'll explain why she's not going to
be living in Starling city thank you so
much so everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do I
know there's still a whole bunch of
questions about second reverse-flash
what's happening with eddie thawne
definitely i think most of those
questions are going to be answered in
the next three episodes the only thing
I'm really worried about is if they lose
Tom Cavanagh for season two of the flash
he is so amazing that it's like you know
can the show maintain it
momentum if they lose one of their best
characters that's a good question for
you guys do you feel like I mean arrow
season 2 they had Slade Wilson amazing
character Manu Bennett amazing actor do
you feel like Rick cos net could rise to
the level of Manu Bennett as like a
season 2 villain it feels like his
character has been riding the bench for
most of the season so it's really hard
to get a read on him as an actor I think
that'll change in the next couple of
episodes so don't forget new episodes of
air on the flash next week be sure to
subscribe to get my videos it's gonna be
you know a little bit Terminator a
little bit groundhog stays scary funny
at the same time gonna be a lot of fun
so if you guys haven't seen it yet you
can click here for my flash video
probably one of the best episodes this
season and you can click here for this
week's agents of shield if you haven't
seen it yet thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow now
let's all do the thing
you